hey guys it's mkbhd back with an hd
video and today we're going to be taking
a look at the blue yeti pro and just a
heads up i recently did a collab video
with product feedback so you can check
that out right here
basically one thing you should know
about this mic right away is it is
absolutely massive you're going to want
to leave room on your desk for this
puppy it measures in at about a foot
tall and about four inches wide anyway
just like the original yeti this mic
comes with the stand you see here which
a lot of other companies fail to include
so good job blue you can see it's pretty
versatile stand as well and you can take
it off the stand and use it with an arm
like i will be and just so you know the
base is weighted nicely so it won't be
sliding around but like some other
things in life you gotta bend it over
and look at the back side the most
important part and this is actually
where the most important part of the
microphone is this is where you can
determine what kind of sound quality you
get out of the yeti pro so starting on
the left there's a usb port to connect
it to your computer they provide that
cable on the top is an analog stereo xlr
connection and they also provide that
xlr cable on the right hand side is a
pretty cool feature it's a no latency
headphone jack for listening to your
recordings live and the bottom holes for
your microphone stand on the front of
the yeti pro here you have your controls
for that latency free headphone jack so
you can listen to yourself louder or
softer or mute the mic all together i
don't know something about the solid
feel of the yeti pro i just really like
pushing our buttons um anyway on that
curvy backside again we have controls
for all the mic patterns so this is
where you can switch between stereo
cardioid bi-directional and
omnidirectional patterns and this is all
thanks to the triple condenser mic array
inside and it's these mics that record
24 bit 192 kilohertz stereo audio that's
four times cd quality audio giggity so
i'm sure you're dying to take a listen
so without any further ado let's switch
from this editor's case sl 150 to the
yeti pro
all right now we're listening to is a
standard recording from the yeti pro
microphone the gain is about medium
recording at 192 kilohertz and 24-bit
stereo sound in the cardioid pattern
with the gain about medium as you can
hear the audio quality is really quite
good very good in the cardioid pattern
for things like vocals and voiceovers
like we're doing now if you do record at
such a high bit rate the file size tends
to be pretty high so if you don't need
such high quality vocals you can turn
that down but of course if you're buying
the blue yeti pro it's such an
investment that you might as well get
the most out of it so i can highly
recommend this microphone based on the
sound that i'm getting out of it as you
can see in the background i have used
the editor's keys sl150 for quite a few
of my videos and i really like it but
the sound quality of the triple capsule
pattern within the yeti pro is really
really impressive so that's pretty much
it for the sound quality and if you like
this video go ahead and make sure you
give it a thumbs up this is basically uh
it's you know overall review of the
microphone as i've had it for a little
bit so thanks for watching this video
guys and i'll talk to you guys later
peace
[Music]
you